you're watching the GameSpot co-op stage
sponsored by Lego Star Wars The Force
awakens
hey everybody welcome back to the
GameSpot co-op stage live at e3 I'm
Alexa ray Correa your resident weeaboo
princess and I am here with my friends
and Renae I just seen I am Jeff katana
yeah are you guys how are you doing
we're great yeah I'm so excited that
you're here I am so excited to be here
this is actually Andrea's idea you and I
were talking about I think it was that
new Nintendo Fire Emblem game and you
were like oh I don't really know much
about yeah we were talking about Tokyo
Mirage sessions sharp Fe which is still
a terrible name twister
so I had told Alexa that I am lacking a
lot of knowledge when it comes to
Japanese games particularly JRPGs and I
had said hey what's up with this you
know Shin Megami Tensei Fire Emblem
mashup what's you know what's the deal
like what are they pulling from each of
these different series and so she was
talking to me about it and was you and
me and Cindy went from how I get right
out and we were just like you know like
having a good job and I said Alexa you
need to come and educate me and teach me
the ways of all the Japanese games and
also like I'm the first to admit I'm
terrible at pronouncing Japanese words I
just I muck it up in the third we're
also here because the same so well my
senpai dang it see I told you you speak
Japanese yeah okay well so when you
think I think Japanese games I feel like
a lot of people when they say oh yeah I
play Japanese games I play Zelda are you
guys
Zelda fans yes chance to play the demo
tomorrow tomorrow have you played a gun
I have not I have yes what do you find a
line at Nintendo and I'm so excited it
feels I mean we talked about it a little
bit elastic meant but it feels very
polished already and I just there's a
level of polish that Nintendo brings to
all their games put this specifically to
the Zelda franchise that makes me so
excited for them taking on a very
Western idea which is this open-world
role-playing game yeah I mean this is
something it
people have been waiting for a pretty
long time yeah but it's here and the
entire booth is pretty much dedicated to
it I mean it looks like a theme park
over there if any of you guys I'm sure
you guys have showed it but it's
incredible and it's really cool to sort
of be able to get our hands on to plate
and that's really the only playable
thing over there it's insane though that
we're all playing it on the system that
we are probably not going to be playing
it on right and xp for both right Jimmy
for both but don't they want it to sell
the new ones like I don't think there
might be some secret thing that we don't
know about that's gonna be in the next
console that we're like alright this is
why we write again it goes back to sort
of like the xbox like okay you saw a 360
you can still play these set games but
you can also play it on xbox like oh
yeah you're going to and I think there's
that console transition for a lot of
people doesn't happen immediately
so we'll see it's it's funny you
mentioned Xbox because what I wanted to
talk to you guys about is the Microsoft
press conference specifically typically
when you think oh we're gonna see a
Japanese game we're gonna see Final
Fantasy Shenmue Last Guardian it's all
well they're all Sony games but well
we're gonna see Japanese devs on the
Sony stage we saw Street Fighter the
first time we saw Tekken 74 consoles was
on the Sony stage so I thought I was
really surprised to see scalebound and
then Tekken and then Final Fantasy 15 of
all games on the Microsoft stage so how
did you guys feel about that did it feel
out of out of place like what did you
think they traditionally haven't been in
the last couple of years I should say
really investing in the Japanese market
I mean they pulled out of TGS I know
they don't really have a presence there
I mean obviously Sony is a Japanese
company so they've been in that market
the entire time so I was surprised too
but I think it's good I think it's a way
for them to reach out to an audience
that has historically been PlayStation
owners and say hey we have great
Hardware too we have partnerships to
come play these games on our console
yeah yeah there was a time when the
first Xbox came out and that was a big
deal like Japanese developers weren't
making games for xbox and Microsoft had
to throw money at the problem and war
Japanese developers because Japan owned
the video game market and if you wanted
a good game on your system you need
it needed to be made in in the East and
things have changed so dramatically that
the West has very much taken over the
sort of big-budget mainstream video
games that sell the best your a and it's
it's kind of crazy how far a sea change
and now it feels like traditionally
Japanese games are kind of underdogs
even a Final Fantasy 15 with a massive
budget and as long as they've been
working on it feels a little bit like an
underdog to me like yeah are the Western
gamers gonna embrace it well those are
the types of games that I ever really
got into like I grew up playing
first-person shooters and Mario is I
mean Mario brand Tendo is a Japanese
company mostly it's Japanese yes exactly
but you know when you think of those
other traditional games that they were
even announcing at the Xbox press
conference I mean I think it's kind of
exciting but also people are playing
games everywhere they're playing mobile
they're playing on handheld devices and
I love what Xbox is doing is is having
that cross promotion with playing
Windows 10 playing on your xbox and sort
of having that play anywhere aspect like
you have to do that like I can't travel
with my xbox but I can take my PC laptop
with me and well they have a smaller one
it looks there's no power brick oh it's
a built-in power supply wow that's great
it's look we're all excited about the
plug and it's also surprising because
there's also no you are saying that Xbox
Windows 10 crossover I wonder if
Microsoft is starting to push them
because there's no there's no Xbox
market in Japan but there is a PC market
so maybe that's them sort of pushing
that duality as well I think there's
always been sort of that you know like
the PC master-race mind so now you can
sort of have both of those and yeah you
might have this amazing console and you
can have a PC that is a hundred times
more powerful that's gonna be cool and
also interesting with VR too because how
are they gonna integrate is this console
gonna be good enough to be able to
handle it you know with the announcement
of you know the new Xbox coming in
holiday really really far away I'm like
you can't do this to us with this teeth
so you know you have to have a powerful
machine to be able to run all of these
VR experiences and that's gonna be
interesting too because no PlayStation
didn't really meant
anything about that you're still running
this VR experience on older hardware so
I don't know there's so much that goes
into it we're talking about Japanese
games so well I won't ask you a question
all chair well it's a big couch as
you're a fan of Japanese games I am and
I'm wondering how you feel about the
Western influence that we see in Final
Fantasy 15 and scalebound because I
actually mourn the loss of turn-based
combat as do I in these giant games but
you know and I look at that what they
showed on stage for Final Fantasy 15 and
I'm like jumping him back in his finger
it doesn't look as fun to me as systems
that have been I mean my favorite I
think my favorite JRPG of all time is
grandia - a good choice and I love I
love the combat system in that way
you're jockeying for position and you're
trying to queue up your attacks those
are dying it feel like those are only
happen now on a handheld systems we're
not seeing that big consoles anymore
I don't know turn-based the real so with
if we're talking about Final Fantasy the
Final Fantasy sort of turned to the
real-time in a little bit with Final
Fantasy 12 or you could use the gambit
system to assign roles to other party
members so they could attack how you
want them to attack but you're still
only controlling one person then in 13
the whole system move to the real-time
combat system I think we are and I think
as developers and as gamers where we
want that we want that immediate action
we want what action games have we want
what shooters have where you make a
decision in real time and it's done you
don't have to wait there's not really
that at that strategy element you have
to move really really really quickly and
I we've seen that in 15 you saw the demo
what did you guys think of the demo I
had no idea what was happening I was
citizen was attacking him I was sitting
there watching it going what's going on
what's going on on the tank right now I
was just confused I was like I'm gonna
ask Alexa about this
my first thought - no I mean well Andrea
and I just pop out of like from the
cabinet
I've only only 15 minutes away from you
I can be there and everything about
Final Fantasy so I just wanted to know
from you like what what was happening
well so can you set a timer for 15
minutes that demo was was a boss fight
the Titan is one of the the summons in
the game Titan has is a recurring giant
creature in other Final Fantasy games so
he's sort of something that longtime
Final Fantasy fans have recognized but
what they were trying to do is they were
trying to fight him and I'm not exactly
sure what was going on there something
you may have noticed was a little
flashing blue light a work point one of
the special powers 415 is the main
character noctis can warp to warp around
the field which can and he can work
between enemies as well and they were
not doing that and I think that's one of
the coolest things about the real-time
combat at 15 and something that makes it
really unique is that ability to warp so
I was really disappointed that they were
not using the work but the biggest the
biggest role-playing game that showed
turn-based combat in a Japanese style is
called a fractured but Hall oh that was
the one world Japanese style
role-playing game yesterday on display
that's nothing to do with the East right
now based on an IP from the West made by
Western developers so it's weird how and
it just makes me kind of sad and I think
that what you said about us wanting
immediate action I think people
overestimate that because people love
their hearthstone people love you
there's examples over and over about
great games that people embrace and they
sell well well what about what about
Pokemon footballs on a moon like me yeah
Pokemon is like its own beast
I checked out I checked out when there
were 300 I'm done yeah there's one that
looks like a pile of garbage and a
keyring like no don't worry it's just
some of these games I'm glad I never
actually got into because I know like
Pokemon would be one of those like yeah
I actually have to collect them all and
I'm not going to be able to do anything
else
so I don't know I mean it's sort of like
this whole other world that I've never
really kind of
got into so it's kind of interesting
because you know when I get bored of
this I'm like alright let's go check out
these other games but there's this whole
other things you can try another game
that was on the Microsoft stage
scalebound made by Platinum Games
creators of Bayonetta vanquish what did
you guys think have you gotten to play
it did you see the demo
I didn't cuz there was a big crab and
that there was a giant crab I thought
that that was another one of those games
it felt unfortunately really easy to
make fun of it so it had this
over-the-top
you know epic boss battle happening but
then he had to put his headphones on so
he could rock out that much harder as he
was playing and I talked to somebody
afterwards though to do the headphones
make him stronger are they like a buff
does he get like special powers from
them they just look cool
they're actually I think the the Jaypee
columns the producer who were who did
the demo once Atrus Galvan was wearing
like a copy of like Drew's headphones so
they look cool
it's like I think they look cool um I'm
really I'm really interested in that
game because Hideki Kamiya is making it
he made Okami
did you play Ogami no oh my god okay so
that's why I am the weekly excited for
scalebound um another Platinum Games
game they're only showing behind closed
doors here near automata very niche
title sequel to the original near
absolutely weird you're all looking at
me like I grew the second a head it's
fine closed auras Alexa you don't need
to rub it in our faces you get the best
appointment okay I got all the weeaboo
appointments it's literally like
everyone's doing like horizon and Call
of Duty and Zelda and then it's like
we've Alice and it's just all the
Japanese are near is near plays like
Bayonetta it's out I think early next
year they just delayed it but if you
like Bayonetta like you should totally
give this game a try very different than
the first near right
oh yeah no the first course near is the
full-on role did you play it I did in
fact Andrea that's where the phrase yeah
more feeling than it is good came from
oh I don't think that game is good but
it's really fun no yeah it did a lot of
its combat didn't have an identity and
it had bullet health segments a
platformer
segments and like over like
first-person-shooter over-the-shoulder
third-person and it was just this
hodgepodge of ideas but the new one is
real solid lots of great combat really
great you guys haven't played Zelda yet
you're at I said you're playing Zelda
whatever he's like can we talk a little
bit about Hideo Kojima
on stage at Sony I'm Japanese then what
the hell was that what the hell indeed I
mean I I don't want to go off on a rant
here by free did you want to see his but
I really wanted to see his but I was
really hoping after the but I got that
one on the stage that did it I was and
then I mean he looked pretty good I'm
just gonna say it
are we supposed to believe he had that
child did he have a c-section I feel bad
that he didn't actually get to have that
child naturally did he have that we
didn't get to see anything below the
waist I was we were sitting in our war
room and there's at least three people
shout show his heart that I can't say
I'm like I mean like big scar I don't
know if he's supposed to be like have
had that baby it had a little bit of her
like a matrix vibe to me with all like
the ink and the plug and the things they
know here's my rant on this do it I
understand that Sony is making a show
and when you have III as this big
platform you want to juice the crowd
Hideo Kojima is a rock star among the
hardcore gaming community it was an
awesome moment it was a really cool
theatrical thing but ultimately it means
nothing
whenever that game comes out five years
from now it's gonna have nothing to do
with what we saw absolutely nothing that
is bizarre imagery that I guarantee you
it's gonna look weird when we finally
play the game because it's gonna bear no
resemblance whatsoever to whatever that
game ends up being they made it in a few
months
that game is years away there it was a
it was a manipulative kind of thing to
do to an audience which is fine because
you're doing a theatrical event you're
juicing the crowd and it's a fun cool
thing to bring out the rock star guy and
show this this video that really means
nothing and is ultimately kind of dumb
are you mad I'm a man
sound bad he's definitely mad frothy
sound I had that baby I just wish you
had it naturally
well it's video Kojima so men giving
birth is not off the table yeah yeah
well thanks everyone for joining us
Japanese games you're watching the game
spot co-op stage and these lovely people
will be back in a bit